[Musica]
Quanti di voi si spostano in macchina la
mattina per andare al lavoro e magari si
sono ritrovati per ore e ore
imbottigliati nel traffico domandandosi
ma quante cose avrei potuto fare in
questo lasso di tempo
oppure quanti Borghi o paesini
meravigliosi abbiamo a disposizione
magari nemmeno sapendolo ma purtroppo
sono disabitati e me trascurati
quante volte entrando in un negozio di
grandi Brand grandi catene di moda e
magari anche a prezzi abbastanza
accessibili siamo ritrovati davanti
questa situazione
e ci siamo domandati Ma questi vestiti
che fine faranno e se non verranno
acquistati Dove andranno come verranno
riciclati
quante volte avremmo voluto vedere il
nostro artista preferito nella città
vicino a noi oppure anche in Italia ma
non le è mai passato in mente di passare
in una zona vicina
quante volte a scuola abbiamo provato a
studiare per ore e ore un argomento Ma
niente quel concetto proprio non
c'entrava in testa
quanti ragazzi e quante ragazze
durante il periodo di pandemia si sono
laureati o si sono laureate da casa
lontano dalle persone care oppure in
presenza in una città non così vicina
dalla propria con accesso limitato
all'evento e quindi le persone non hanno
potuto assistere uno degli eventi più
importanti per la vita di ogni studente
per fortuna Io mi sono laureato nel
metaverso così mi sono evitato un
viaggio a Torino in piena estate con 45
gradi all'ombra e me ne sono stato
comodo in piscina con il computer sulle
gambe Ah che bellezza
Eh No in realtà non è andata proprio
così prima di tutto io all'università a
Torino ci sono andato e secondo magari
ci avesse una piscina
mi chiamo Edoardo Di Pietro e sono stato
il primo laureato nel metaverso Ma cosa
vuol dire facciamo un attimo un passo
indietro Aprile 2021 stavo per
concludere gli esami e mi avvantaggio
inizia a cercare un relatore per la mia
tesi di laurea ne trovo uno inizio a
documentarmi e iniziamo a lavorare
insieme
settembre del 2021 Dopo alcune settimane
di lavoro
Purtroppo con il professore decidiamo di
abbandonare la strada presa a causa di
alcuni accordi non trovati quindi mi
ritrovo di nuovo ad aprile io che mi ero
avvantaggiato e volevo laurearmi entro
la fine dell'anno cercando di rifare di
capire come fare per riprendere questa
epopea decido di contattare il
professore che mi aveva assunto da poco
all'interno della sua azienda per un
tirocinio insieme troviamo un argomento
un po' particolare Un caso studio
avvenuto pochi mesi prima all'interno
della sua agenzia la festa di Natale
aziendale all'interno del videogioco
Minecraft
questo è l'argomento
analizzare gli spazi virtuali sociali
usando il concetto cardine del metaverso
partendo da dal web e studiando come
siamo arrivati fino a questo punto e
quali tecnologie stanno alla base
ottobre del 2021 Mark Zuckerberg
annuncia i rebranding della sua azienda
con tanto tutto sul termine metaverso e
il termine arriva sulla bocca di tutti
quindi il mio lavoro triplica
ci avviciniamo al giorno dell'evento Io
parto dalla Toscana
lasciando qui tutti i miei canali o
comunque in giro per il mondo però
andava bene lo stesso perché avevo
trovato un modo per far sì che tutti
partecipassero alla mia discussione di
laurea nonostante le restrizioni e
nonostante la lontananza
primo luglio del 2022 è un giorno
caldissimo per laurearsi arrivo
all'università la situazione che mi
ritrovo davanti è questa
già una tesi di laurea è complicata
potete immaginare il mio stato d'animo
in quel momento
quindi preparo tutto una un pc per le
slide uno per controllare lo spazio
virtuale un tablet per gestire il mio
Avatar delle cuffiette per sentire cosa
accadeva all'interno del metaverso
entro di scudo sudo mi danno il voto
applausi e esco purtroppo devo dare poca
rilevanza l'ho detto in maniera così
veloce perché ciò che è successo dopo e
niente rispetto all'evento che vi stavo
raccontando
eventi convention programmi TV oppure
persone che mi contattavano per capire
cosa fosse il metaverso oppure per fare
due chiacchiere con me dopo un po' di
tempo
riparto mi prendo un po' di giorni per
capire cosa stesse succedendo in quel
periodo nella mia vita visto le
opportunità che mi si erano presentate e
piano piano con sempre più curiosità
riparto anche con qualche incertezza
perché ovviamente non sapevo a cosa
stessi andando incontro ed eccomi qua
oggi dopo aver aperto una startup a
parlare a questo evento di un pianeta B
una realtà alternativa
un qualcosa un posto migliore nel quale
rifugiarci E allora io vi vorrei
proporre un'alternativa al nostro alla
nostra realtà ma questa volta digitale
il metaverso Ma che cos'è il metaverso
la parola metaverso è composta da meta
proposizione greca che indica qualcosa
che va oltre al di là e da versus
derivante dal participio passato del
verbo latino vertere che sta a
significare raccolte in una unità un
tutto insieme
In poche parole possiamo definirlo un
oltre universo
esso viene identificato come una zona di
convergenza di spazi virtuali online
tridimensionali e interattivi
accessibili dagli utenti con un proprio
Alter Ego digitale detto Avatar per
fruire le esperienze può dar normale
sono diverse le caratteristiche
racchiuse dentro a questo termine
decentralizzazione dematerializzazione
socialità
nell'immaginario più comune si può
accedere a questi spazi virtuali tramite
dei visori o dei device indossabili più
verosimilmente oggi però il metaverso è
accessibile da i device più canonici
come smartphone PC console di gioco
non è decentralizzato ma è controllato
da grandi aziende e si avvicina al
concetto di spazio virtuale sociale
simile più famosi videogiochi come
Roblox
è ancora un po' più complesso da
spiegare ma questa è già un'ottima
infarinatura
abbiamo visto che il metaverso su di me
ha avuto un impatto importante ma quale
impatto può avere su molti di noi
andiamo a vedere alcuni punti
comunicazione e collaborazione team di
lavoro dislocati in diverse parti del
globo potranno lavorare comunicare in
ambienti immersivi lavorando Su progetti
disegni modificando oggetti 3D anche se
si trovano in diverse parti appunto del
mondo
turismo locale e riqualificazione del
territorio
un turista per esempio di New York
potrebbe per decidere dove andare in
vacanza fare un tour virtuale del luogo
il Borgo di Colle di Val d'Elsa ammirare
alcuni scorci della Toscana oppure
assistere alla preparazione di un piatto
tipico per poi arrivare sul posto e fare
tutte queste esperienze una volta in
vacanza il piatto cucinarlo e magari
anche mangiarlo oppure se vogliamo
proprio sognare
possiamo immaginare che questa persona
possa fare una scelta di fuggire da dal
caos della città e
trasferirsi in uno dei quei Borghi che
vi ho nominato all'inizio
riqualificando il territorio e dandogli
una nuova vita
sostenibilità ambientale il metaverso
potrebbe ridurre l'impatto dovuto
l'impatto ambientale dovuto agli
spostamenti io che mi sposto spesso per
andare a convention o eventi per
interventi di mezz'ora magari potrei
risparmiare questo questo viaggio
facendo sì che l'evento sia magari in
forma ibrida quindi un intervento dal
metaverso
e commerce o immersive commerce potremo
entrare con il nostro Avatar magari che
anche le nostre taglie le nostre misure
all'interno di uno Store virtuale
scegliere l'abito che fa il caso nostro
provarselo quando abbiamo visto che fa
al caso nostro farsi spedire
direttamente a casa
Questo potrebbe ridurre
la sovrapproduzione di questi abiti
Perché verranno fabbricati solo se
acquistate Se provate che impatto può
avere tutto questo sul fast fashion
Entertainment Sì perché se L'artista non
viene da noi allora siamo noi ad andare
dall'artista però in maniera digitale in
maniera virtuale con certi eventi mostre
sono tutte cose sono già state
sperimentate all'interno del metaverso
questo mezzo questa innovazione potrebbe
sconvolgere e rivoluzionare il mondo del
divertimento delle Entertainment e il
gaming fa da apripista in tutto questo
c'è sempre una più forte correlazione
tra intrattenimento e cultura Infatti
l'istruzione e formazione
degli studenti potranno
apprendere studiare L'Antica Roma
immergendosi in una riproduzione di uno
scenario dell'epoca e quindi vedere
toccare con mano osservare discutere
giocare anche insieme All'interno dello
spazio oppure apprendisti medici
potrebbero lavorare simulare
un'operazione a cuore aperto in un
ambiente immersivo con medici connessi
da tutte le parti del mondo con
professionisti o colleghi senza però
mettere a rischio la vita di una persona
questi sono solo alcune delle
possibilità ma accanto alle molte
opportunità ci sono anche moltissimi
dubbi che attanellano questo termine
controllo e privacy sì perché se saremo
tutti in questo metaverso molti in
questo spazio virtuale chi garantirà la
nostra identità digitale questa grande
mole di dati a chi andrà sarà in mano
alle Big Tech oppure sarà tutto
decentralizzato e Open Source come
teorizzato da Nier Stevenson nel 1992
dal creatore del termine
governance il metaverso è ancora una
tecnologia in via di sviluppo quindi non
c'è una vera e propria regolamentazione
cosa faranno gli stati e le istituzioni
o le aziende per prevenire i crimini
digitali un patto psicologico e sociale
questi spazi virtuali saranno
coinvolgenti immersivi Ma quindi ci
distaccheremo completamente dalla realtà
oppure riusciremo a trovare un
equilibrio a conviverci con questa
innovazione
digital divide e accessibilità se io
provassi a chiedere in questa in questo
teatro quante persone Hanno già fatto
accesso al metaverso probabilmente in
pochissimi alzerebbero la mano ecco il
metaverso non sarà accessibile a tutti e
immaginate anzi che secondo un recente
report delle Nazioni Unite un terzo
della popolazione mondiale vive ancora
completamente disconnessa un terzo di
questi
il 97% di questi vive in paesi in via di
sviluppo e quindi questa tecnologia per
chi è
Ovviamente per la parte più agiata per
la porzione più agiata del nostro
pianeta invece che espandere le
opportunità a tutti pare che queste
opportunità anche economiche siano date
alla parte di popolazione che magari non
ne ha nemmeno bisogno Questo non fa
altro che incrementare il cosiddetto
digital divide il divario digitale
impatto ambientale Come ho detto prima
il metaverso o magari contribuire la
riduzione dell'impatto ambientale dovuto
agli spostamenti ma ci sono tecnologie
hardware e software che inquinano
tantissimo mi viene in mente il cloud il
mining oppure i server stessi
per adesso le persone all'interno del
metaverso ce le devi trascinare con
singoli eventi in detti da Brand da
persone famose o anche meno famose come
ho fatto io per la mia tesi di laurea ma
un giorno probabilmente non ci sarà
bisogno di avere un pretesto per entrare
perché sarà importante Come controllare
la nostra casella di posta elettronica
la mattina
E allora come approcciare a questo
metaverso a questo nuovo mondo io non
sono qua per dare una soluzione a tutti
i mali Ma come per ogni cosa ci vuole
consapevolezza e conoscenza del mezzo
per ridurre al minimo qualsiasi tipo di
rischio e un tempestivo intervento da
parte di aziende di Season Maker la
metafora che voglio riportare oggi è
quella del fuoco che si può benissimo
applicare alla tecnologia in generale un
po' tutto il fuoco possiamo utilizzarlo
sia per riscaldarci e per cucinare
prelibatezze ma anche per fare qualcosa
di un po' meno etico Come incendiare un
bosco L'importante è accendere questa
fiamma in un posto sicuro e riuscire a
domarla senza che essa prende il
sopravvento e bruci tutto
Ecco la stessa regola vale anche per il
metaverso serve coscienza e
consapevolezza e per questo io sono
contento di essere qua oggi a
raccontarvi questa cosa perché da quando
il termine si è avvicinato all'opinione
pubblica ma succede con molte tecnologie
qualche scintilla sta già andando dove
non dovrebbe andare E allora vi lascio
alcune parole chiave da tenere in
considerazione una volta che vi
avvicinerete al metaverso consapevolezza
equilibrio buon senso e tutela tutela di
dati della privacy delle persone a noi
care tutela della diversità o delle
nuove generazioni
vogliamo veramente che il metaverso sia
un posto bellissimo Fantastico in cui
rifugiarsi
Io mi sono immaginato un futuro
lontanissimo e distopico quando nel
metaverso praticamente avremmo già fatto
tutto e allora la nostra immaginazione
sarà ormai satura
E allora sogneremo di correre Magari a
piedi nudi banalmente una cosa
semplicissima a piedi nudi in un prato
andando incontro al tramonto facendosi
accarezzare dal vento e respirando
l'odore di erba fresca e tutto questo lo
faremo in uno spazio virtuale costruito
da noi
un pianeta B che sarà però finto e
distaccato dalla realtà quindi non
subiamo la tecnologia come in molti
stiamo facendo oggi
comprendiamola accogliamola e rendiamola
ciò che vogliamo rendiamo le macchine
più umane e non l'uomo più in macchina
il metaverso dovrà implementare la
realtà e non sostituirlo
Quindi adesso è il nostro momento adesso
tocca a tutti noi Grazie
[Applauso]